as human beings we're very resilient if
you could rewind time
[Music]
who knows what's going on at this point
do you remember how it felt throughout
the pandemic it's frustrating
we finally thought we'd get our senior
year the roller coaster I hope that 2022
is a hell of a lot better than 2021
because that was terrible of skeptic
to despair it's
it can't be worse hope and acceptance we
are going in a positive direction I'd
say realistically cautious covid-19 took
a toll however new research suggests the
extent of its effect on global mental
health might be relatively limited
during much of the pandemic you know
people have have assumed that there
would be a you know tsunami was a word
that was used a mental health
catastrophes a canadian-led research
team went through 137 studies from
around the world that tracked mental
health indicators before and during the
pandemic for the most part things either
had not changed or had changed minimally
however the study does know women have
struggled which comes as no surprise to
clinical psychologist Kathy kamkar
searching me a lot of straws and then
also hoping to be able to to manage it
all sometimes there is a tendency to
engage in self-criticism or wanting to
be a better person or a better mother or
did this feeling of failure the lead
author notes there are some
informational gaps they are still
looking to fill we had data in
adolescence but virtually none on
children so Under 12 years old we also
didn't have data on people like
those who are working in Elder Care or
medical care still the team believes
this study highlights how when the chips
were down people came together we helped
each other along the way to prevent
having some of those struggles and that
you know we can do this we need to keep
on keeping on Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto